right-wing terrorism unfortunately
showing no signs of abating in the new
year still early but we have news of
just a horrible right-wing terrorist
attack that took place in Germany and
we've been speaking about the context of
what's going on not only in the United
States but also in Europe this context
of growing far right-wing nationalism
extremist movements and parties in much
of Europe we've talked about it in
Hungary Poland is having a major issue
with it stefan molyneux seems to
absolutely love it talk about that a
couple of weeks ago France is having
this issue many other countries
including Germany as well and that is
where this story took place in Batra
Germany a 50 year old man drove his car
straight at a pedestrian who managed to
jump out of the way right after midnight
on New Year's Day but four people ended
up injured when the driver kept going
and drove into a crowd with his silver
Mercedes at another location the man
fled but was eventually arrested and
local police say that he made racist
comments and anti-immigrant for
anti-foreigner immigrant I guess it's
the same thing
comments and this has every indication
of being another one of these right-wing
deliberate anti-immigrant attacks
hitting Syrian and Afghan citizens in
the incident police ultimately arrested
the man in the city of Essen where the
guy kept trying to hit people with the
same car at a bus stop we heard from
Herbert rule who's the top security
official in the particular region where
this took place saying quote the man had
the clear intention to kill foreigners
they also put out a statement and that
statement says that investigators
suspect it was a deliberate attack that
may be linked to the xenophobic views of
the driver police also believed that
this was a premeditated incident and
very quickly zero days since the last
right-wing terror attack in 2019 very
quickly getting that counter back to
zero and
is really nothing positive about these
stories I mean it's just horrible in
every single way if we have to find some
silver lining here or some way to say
this wasn't as bad as it could have been
it's that no one was killed this guy is
going to go to prison for a long time
he's sitting there in custody now
presumably knowing that he didn't
succeed at killing a singer a single
person and and I it's sick to even use
the language of he succeeded or didn't
succeed at killing people it's what he
wanted to do and he failed and as of
when I looked at a few recent reports
the attacker hadn't yet been named I'm
sure that by the time you hear the story
he likely will have been named that's
totally fine with me not to name this
guy named him later when the trial gets
going but we haven't been reporting
attacker names for a while and of course
much later on we sometimes have to
mention the names when we say so-and-so
is now at trial and that's the attacker
from X Y Z incident or whatever the case
may be but for those who were doing this
for infamy or notoriety or whatever
other self-aggrandizing reasons they
have to do it I'm not going to be
providing them with an ounce of that by
even naming them I know that there are
lots of other shows that are doing the
same thing and for the most part our
audience has gotten in touch and said
they agree they write in and say David I
I noticed now going back a few stories
that you've not been mentioning the
names of the terrorist attackers and I
actually like that and I didn't even
realize that it was something you
weren't mentioning in other words it's
so irrelevant what their names are other
than I guess you know them personally in
some way that it doesn't even really
feel like it's missing and that's
basically been my policy not a huge deal
I just don't know what I add to the
story by naming these people it's
another guy it's almost always guys men
who tried to kill people and who's in
jail his name doesn't much matter to me
but keeping him off the streets and
unable to do this again is what is
actually the important thing